à l'autre look tube halo l'aktu merci
aux anneaux ne tirez pas d'eau pour
l'instant s'il vous plaît les chéris
c'est très simple je vous pose une
question si vous répondez bien tout ce
passe bien c'est vous pouvez viser
quelqu'un si vous répondez mal tous les
autres vous viseront avec leur pistolet
on multiplie rex ionel ao je vous le dis
je vous dis franchement et gagne c'est
parce qu'il fait chaud on a besoin se
refroidit et bien alors ça fait du bien
je sais pas si ça et bah écoutez ça
rafraîchit en plus isabelle ça voilà
elle adore l'eau e question pour vous
valérie démarque par vous bien sûr et on
fait le tour de l'actualité
benoît paire mon ami benoît ouais c'est
le boss sur instagram
pourquoi parce qu'il a montré son cuche
et il a fait de photo de ses fesses
et ouais ouais ouais ben haim très
bonnes réponses qui qui au demeurant
assez joli oui passé attendez web et
c'est le bon moment alors ouais non non
non alors 3 2 1 pompe et 3,2 à pomper
beinheim et il est normal que vous allez
tomber
isabelle et ben vous l'a dit ce récit
vous gagnez pas là un dollar
mais alors c'est pas grave je vous en
avais encore regarder votre père qu'on
se le dise pour les sportifs c'est très
beau duo coronavirus commence à durer
trop longtemps empêché de se défouler
sur les terrains depuis presque deux
mois certains pète littéralement un
câble et ça se voit sur leurs réseaux
sociaux c'est le cas du tennisman benoît
paire sur son compte il a en effet posté
une photo de lui accompagnée de la
légende pour prothèses qu'elle reprend
cette saison une photo sur laquelle il a
transformé son boxeur en string une
publication qui a beaucoup amusé et ses
fans et ses amis sportifs
bref à défaut de pouvoir briller sur les
terrains benoît compte bien bronzé à la
piscine
benoît hamon frérot de jean bouin store
et je vous rappelle qu'on va faire un
gros gros challenge avec benoît paire
benoît paire et stan wawrinka contre
gaël monfils
et moi en double au paddle tennis c'est
comme des i c'est sûr c'est un sport qui
est en train de faire fureur et on va
l'organiser
je vous dis dans les prochaines semaines
normalement on va pouvoir l'organiser et
on essayera même de leur diffuser sur
ses beats by dr
vous êtes au même niveau que les
internationaux de tennis alors là c'est
paddle et d'ipad apple tennis je suis
4000e joueurs français il est comment
wawrinka votre nom moi je suis également
fils brink eye pet à dakar en voilà et
je vous le dis c'est ça qui est fou je
suis c'est une barca c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui parient sur nous
pour et parier voilà un très bon bah non
non non gaël monfils vous êtes très bon
gaël monfils est un tueur et fait partie
des dix meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
voilà après a priori l'a fait un ton un
jour il est il a explosé excusez moi je
connais rien en tennis écoles pas d'elle
pour moi sa flotte sur l'eau le paddle
moi je croyais c'est sympa de jc comme
centre le squash et le tennis c'est
écrit-elle et c'est très très anormal a
cessé est ce qu'il existe des terrains
où on peut rassembler le public de
paddle on peut pas si bien sûr bien
alors pourquoi vous attendez pas plus
tard qu et du public pour donner cette
joie aux gens de voir justement wawrinka
et si une répétition mal j'ai bien et on
donnera tout l'argent il ya de graves
bravo faudrait toujours le coeur sur la
main chaude est là bas c'est pour ça
qu'on aime